avec nos didier houssin président du
comité d'urgence qu'avait 19 de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
professeur houssin bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur alors
d'abord vous avez publié un livre vous
êtes à l'eau à mèze première question
que les gens se pose est ce que cette
pandémie va finir un jour on va devoir
cohabiter avec le virus par de
nombreuses
en fait aujourd'hui je crois que
personne ne sait un personne ne sait les
deux scénarios sont possibles il ya même
peut-être d'autres scénarios encore mais
il est possible qu effectivement soit on
est à cohabiter comment cohabitent avec
les virus de la grippe chaque année tant
bien que mal et puis où on peut aussi
assister à une sorte de disparition du
virus mais qui apparaîtra peut-être un
autre 20 autres jours plus tard sous une
nouvelle forme un nouveau coronavirus en
fait en fait on ne sait pas parce que
haut dé au départ de cette crise on
avait beaucoup un vocabulaire guerrier
on n'en faut abattre faut tuer faut
vaincre le virus et on s'aperçoit peu à
pain qu'on est venu à la cohabitation
nécessaire
oui alors il fallait quand même je crois
au début mobiliser beaucoup les énergies
et malgré tout il ya des actions
conduites qui ont une efficacité
les mesures dites non pharmacologiques
le port du masque la distance la
ventilation des espaces fermés le
l'hygiène des mains sont des mesures
extrêmement important pour réduire le
risque et puis il ya la vaccination est
donc je pense qu'il ne faut pas négliger
malgré tout les actions efficaces qui
ont été conduites et qui ont réclamé une
certaine mobilisation au départ bon par
là de mesures efficaces ya la
vaccination
je vous donne deux chiffres professeur
houssin pour la planète première dose
couverture vaccinale de premières doses
33% l'échelle mondiale deuxième dose est
encore plus bas 25% je montre une carte
c'est très inégale au canada en est à 66
% en europe 45 ça c'est les deux doses
états unis 51 asie 25 à fred à peine 3
pour ça alors il a une inéquité on voit
dans certains pays comme le canada comme
en europe on discute les états unis en
discute déjà de la troisième dose alors
que la majorité de la planète n'a même
pas eu sa première dose vous en êtes
dans l'analyse
vous vous mettez le doigt sur une l'une
des difficultés majeures actuelle à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés quand je
dis nous je mets un peu à la place du
directeur général de l'om mais c'est
aussi de nombreux acteurs c'est-à-dire
que effectivement la vaccination et
efficace aujourd'hui elle et elle s'est
bien développé même si elle n'a pas
encore atteint un niveau suffisant dans
l'est entre guillemets les pays riches
mais la difficulté c'est
qu'effectivement les pays pauvres ont
accès aujourd'hui limitée à la
vaccination il n'est pas nul mais il est
trop faible et vous avez raison
d'évoquer la alors certains la présente
comme une alternative peut-être que ça
n'est pas une alternative mais
effectivement va falloir va-t-il falloir
surprotéger en proposant une troisième
cause - rappel à certaines personnes ou
vaudrait-il pas mieux essayer
d'accentuer l'initiative kovacs pour
donner accès en plus grand nombre aux
vaccins dans des pays aujourd'hui
démunis et vous répondez quoi cette
question est ce qu'on devrait
privilégier le jeu
aujourd'hui je réponds qu'il vaut mieux
essayer de développer la vaccination
dans les pays démunis parce que il est
vraisemblable que si on veut tenter de
maîtriser cette maxime cette pandémie il
faut quand même essayer d'avoir une vue
globale et penser à la maîtrise et à la
surface du globe en totalité je boucle
la boucle on parlait de cohabiter avec
avec la coved cambier de ta encore on
sera en alerte comme ça d'après vous
vous savez le comité d'urgence que j'ai
l'honneur de présider il se réunit à peu
près tous les trois mois et on lui pose
uniquement une seule la première
question qu'on lui pose c'est est-ce que
c'est toujours une urgence de santé
publique de portée internationale et je
dois dire que jusqu'à présent la réponse
est a été unanimement oui vous le
comprenez bien on aura une nouvelle
réunion en octobre je pressens que en
octobre affaire ne sera pas terminée
maintenant aller plus loin dans la
prédiction savez si woody allen qui
disait les prévisions sont toujours
difficiles en particulier à propos du
futur et cette pandémie est capable de
nous réserver quand même des mauvaises
surprises encore ok alors jusqu'à la fin
de l'automne en tout cas on est en
urgence sanitaire
oui à celui c'est très vraisemblable à
moins d'un miracle je vois mal comment
fin octobre on pourrait le comité
pourrait dire au directeur général ne ça
n'est plus une urgence de santé publique
de portée internationale
on croit mal aux miracles en tout cas
simplifiée didier houssin professeur
président du comité d'urgence comme u19
de l'om est merci d'avoir parlé
merci de votre avis dessus bord